TONIGHT.
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: AFTER MUELLER'S
REMARKS YESTERDAY IT WASN'T
SIMPLY OUT DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTIAL FIELD THAT LOST
ITS MIND.
HOLLYWOOD OBVIOUSLY DID TOO
LED BY ACTOR ROBERT DE NIRO
HE STARTED A NEW PUBLIC
SERVICE ANNOUNCEMENT THAT
CLAIMS THE PRESIDENT
OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE.
WATCH.
THIS YOU MAY HAVE SEEN ME ON
"SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE" AS A
CERTAIN FEDERAL PROSECUTOR
THAT WAS ACTING.
BUT NOW WE
ARE GOING TO HEAR FROM SOME
REAL FEDERAL PROSECUTORS.
I HAVE SO MUCH ADMIRATION
FOR THEIR INTELLIGENCE AND
DEDICATION TO THEIR WORK.
RECENTLY OTHER A THOUSAND
FORMER FEDERAL PROSECUTORS
WHO SERVED UNDER BOTH
REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTS HAVE UNITED TO
SIGN A STATEMENT TO HELP
AMERICANS UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
ACTUALLY IN THE MUELLER
REPORT.
THEIR CONCLUSION SHOULD
TROUBLE US ALL.
IN THE WORDS OF THE MUELLER
REPORT NO PERSON IS ABOVE
THE LAW.
>> Tucker: NO PERSON IS
ABOVE THE LAW.
BUT CERTAIN RICH WELL-KNOWN
PEOPLE WOULD LIKE AN OUTSIDE
ROLE IN GUIDING WHAT AMERICA
DOES NEXT.
ROBERT DE NIRO WOULD FIT
INTO THAT SMALL CATEGORY.
THIS IS PART OF A LONG TERM
OBSESSION CONTINUE
OBSESSION DONTINUE
OBSESSION DINTINUE
OBSESSION DI NINUE
OBSESSION DI NERUE
OBSESSION DI NEROE
OBSESSION DI NERO HAS WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> IT'S BEYOND SURREAL WHAT
THIS GUY HAS DONE.
>> HAVE YOU CALLED HIM A
MUTT.
>> HE IS A MUTT.
>> YOU STILL BELIEVE IS HE A
MUTT.
>> EVERY WORD I SAID THEN I
MEAN TODAY.
>> THIS [BLEEP] IDIOT IS THE
PRESIDENT.
THE GUY IS A [BLEEP] FOOL.
COME ON.
>> HOW DARE HE SAY THE
THINGS HE DOES.
OF COURSE I WANT TO PUNCH
HIM IN THE FACE.
[CHEERS]
>> Tucker: THE MAN WHO YELLS
AT HIS DRIVER SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF ALL OF US IN THE
RICH PERSON WORLD.
STEIN ONE OF OUR FAVORITE
COLUMNISTS JOINS US TONIGHT
I DON'T UNDERSTAND AND I
KNOW WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT IT
BEFORE.
WHY IS IT IF YOU ARE ROBERT
DE NIRO OR ANY OF THESE
PEOPLE AT THE PINNACLE YOU
ARE MONDAY MANIACAL ABOUT
TRUMP.
WHY THE ON SESSIONS?
>> I THINK IT GETS BACK TO
THE THE FAMOUS LINE BACK
WHEN NIXON WON AND THE NEW
YORK'S FILM CRITIC WROTE
THAT SHE DIDN'T KNOW ANYONE
WHO VOTED FOR NIXON.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
>> IN THIS CASE IT'S EVEN
WORSE THAT THEY DON'T KNOW
ANYONE.
THEY LOATHE TRUMP.
THEY DON'T KNOW ANYONE WHO
VOTED FOR TRUMP.
THEREFORE, BECAUSE THEY SEE
THEMSELVES AS EXEMPLARS AS
EVERYDAY ORDINARY AMERICANS
TRUMP CANNOT HAVE WON WHICH
IS WHY THIS WHOLE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION THING GOT GOING.
IT'S INTERESTING TO ME, FOR
EXAMPLE, WE ARE DOING REAL
DAMAGE TO IMPORTANT ASPECTS
OF OUR SOCIETY THIS LETTING
ROBERT DE NIRO MAKE THE
RUNNING ON THIS.
ROBERT DE NIRO INTRODUCES A
GROUP OF ABOUT 12
PROSECUTORS ON THAT VIDEO
REPRESENTING 1,000.
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS
WHO SAY THAT TRUMP IS GUILTY
OF OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
NOW, TWO THINGS.
IF YOU THOUGHT TRUMP WAS
REALLY GUILTY OF OBSTRUCTION
OF JUSTICE, AND YOU WANTED
TO DO IMPARTIAL JUSTICE, WHY
WOULD YOU STICK A MAN WHO IS
MOST FAMOUS FOR SAYING F
TRUMP AT THE TONY AWARDS ON
THE FRONT OF THAT VIDEO?
WHATEVER THAT IS, THAT'S NOT
EVEN THE POTENTIAL IMPARTIAL
JUSTICE.
AND SECONDLY, JEWELS TO GO
BACK TO WHAT YOU AND SEAN
WERE TALKING ABOUT WITH THIS
NEW STANDARD WHEREBY YOU
HAVE TO BE PROCLAIMED
INNOCENT WHY THE
INNOCENT BHY THE
INNOCENT BYY THE
INNOCENT BY TTHE
INNOCENT BY THEE
INNOCENT BY THE STATE.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH JUST TO BE
NOT GUILTY YOU HAVE TO BE
PROCLAIMED INNOCENT.
WE HAVE SOMETHING WEIRDER
GOING ON WITH THESE
PROSECUTORS.
WE HAVE A JURY OF
PROSECUTORS THAT IS COMPLETE
ALICE IN WONDERLAND
INTERPRETATION OF THE
BALANCE OF COMMON LAW LAW
FOR A THOUSAND YEARS.
IT'S A COMPLETE NONSENSE,
TUCKER.
>> Tucker: DOESN'T IT MAKE
IT EASIER?
YOU DON'T REALLY HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT THE OUTCOME WHEN
YOU HAVE THE PROSECUTORS
ACTING AS THE JURY, YOU KNOW
THE VERDICT IS GOING TO BE
GUILTY, RIGHT?
ISN'T THAT STREAMLINE
PROCESS?
>> YEAH.
I KNOW.
ESPECIALLY WITH THE STINKING
CORRUPT FEDERAL JUSTICE SAID
ON YOUR SHOW BEFORE.
YOU KNOW, THIS IS WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THE DATE
AT WHICH ROBERT MUELLER KNEW
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION OR
CONSPIRACY.
>> Tucker: THAT'S RIGHT.
>> BECAUSE EVERYTHING AFTER
THAT JUST GOES TO THE
AMERICAN METHOD OF THE
PROCESS, THE PUNISHMENT.
AND FOR TRUMP TO BE INDICTED
FOR OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE
FOR SOMETHING HE SAID SIX
MONTHS AFTER ROBERT MUELLER
KNEW THERE WAS NO COLLUSION
OR CONSPIRACY MOUNTAIN OF
PERVERSIONS THAT FEDERAL
JUSTICE HAS HEAPED ON
TRADITIONAL COMMON LAW
PROTECTIONS.
>> Tucker: I WOULD NOT WANT
TO BE CHARGED WITH A CRIME
RIGHT NOW.
I NEVER THOUGHT I WOULD SAY
THAT I WOULD BE WORRIED.
>> NO.
I WILL DRIVE YOU ACROSS THE
BORDER TO CANADA.
GET UNDER THE TARP IN MY
PICKUP, TUCKER.
IT'S A FREE DEAL.
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T WIN WITH
THESE GUYS.